[Music]
hi hi what are you doing here today I
was told I was going to guess who is a
[ __ ] away
for those you you said me you me him him
okay
that's the video for the people that
[Laughter]
somebody who prioritizes maximizing the
number of people they sleep with they do
the same things over and over again try
and make you feel special but you have
the same lines they're unoriginal yeah
that's how I feel about women in online
dating
why do you think you are able to do this
because I've been around it a lot and
I've seen the actions dudes take to get
women would you say you're a [ __ ] boy no
I certainly hope not a [ __ ] boy is just
like a douchebag they don't know their
douchebags that's not true that [ __ ] boy
don't know [ __ ] boy knows generally he's
a [ __ ] boys they're just not the one
minute oh okay they're not gonna own
that [ __ ] why would they own the title
why were they on the title this man said
he's not a [ __ ] boy I bet you if you
lined up a few of his Exes from the
girls he dated they probably disagree to
be fair though women be giving out that
[ __ ] like licorice yeah
at a state fair or old private
Network you're a [ __ ] boy you're a [ __ ]
boy everybody's a [ __ ] boy hey y'all be
generous with that [ __ ] too
maybe seven dinner
me again
that's crazy though yeah that's good for
somebody don't even bang them say hey
I'm not interested in seeing you again
oh you're a [ __ ] boy shut up get the
[ __ ] out of here yo you just show
somebody a good time and they don't get
the outcome they want what's your
favorite season in New York my first my
favorite season in New York yeah hey yo
ma yo hey yo ma hey yo come here for me
hey yo [ __ ] you then season that's
exactly what the ladies do that's what
they do they don't get their way [ __ ]
you then that's that's got a little dick
yeah you a [ __ ] boy oh you're probably
gay throw that [ __ ] out Ginger they do
the same thing but differently so it
really doesn't look like it's the same
thing do you think only men can be [ __ ]
boys absolutely not I have been through
my fuckboy stage no no see see when
you're when you're doing that it's not a
football you a [ __ ] up
see what I'm saying it's like the toxic
masculinity when men do this talks about
when women do it it's still possible
you're not being a [ __ ] boy you're being
a [ __ ] yeah you own that so I think [ __ ]
boys lie so in addition to guessing the
[ __ ] boy I also want you to guess some
other dating personality clingy as [ __ ]
[ __ ] boy oh gender neutral [ __ ] boy
gender neutral [ __ ] boy
Oh my days Oh my days I listen the
people up in Seattle are so what was it
Washington who are these people bro
hopeless romantic yeah uh you don't see
too much of that anymore huh no mama's
boy you think you're the crazy one oh my
gosh yeah I think it's thrown too much
at women sometimes just for having
emotions and putting them out there but
I am crazy
you know what the thing is I didn't want
to give her crazy because of all the
stereotyping [ __ ] but girls are not
helping how would you how would you
identify yourself
I'm chilling
I'm chilling
two people I gotta stick up their ass
about everything you want to chill you
wanna hang out no okay I'm chilling you
don't want to see anymore okay I'm
chilling what you mean you don't want to
chill man it's okay whatever man like
I'm not gonna force you to kill me if
you want to chill me like I'm chilling
whatever go do you no what I want to
know is do you want me dead or not
no I'm chill you want to chill together
you want to have a good relaxing time no
it's not complicated hello
what's your name Mazzy you ever been in
a relationship before
so they broke up with me tell me about
the the last date you went on we went to
do karaoke I sang uh saying it so by
Weezer Say It Ain't So not a crazy
person song not the song of a ghoster do
you feel like you constantly need to be
around people yes I cannot be alone the
Hopeless Romantic yeah that's supposed
to give me the same exact vibes
foreign
that's in the list of the song that you
put and why people go crazy okay I think
you're clingy as [ __ ]
there you are hi I'm Sophie nice to meet
you I'm Ashton I like your outfit you
look nice giving Dolly Parton with them
boots they look nice
if they don't get that [ __ ] right I
don't know listen I don't know what's
going on but I just know if you was in
Ukraine and you was trying to drop
you you taking both the right you pick
up two rifles yeah we need extra
soldiers that's you have you cheated
once I learned my lesson no you can't be
the total package of me and you cheat
how would your partner describe you
confident sexy okay I'm just gonna go
with my gut and say hopeless romantic
okay I believe you to be Ashton the
total package congratulations oh wow
you're all that in a bag of chips I'm
thinking hopeless romantic right now hey
how's it going I like how non-descript
he's dressed someone who's like
non-descript what other personality
traits would you associate well they're
not attention seeking I think a [ __ ] boy
wants the attention because attention
would maximize the likelihood that they
are able to [ __ ] right
that's a chat that's a chat you don't
guess no attention you get no [ __ ]
that was a chat
yeah these little [ __ ] boy would have to
be
that he [ __ ]
all right how would you describe
yourself in a relationship very loving
I'm usually the role of like the
listener there you are sir why are you
saying clingy it was a couple of things
he said like he's a good listener the
most clingy Partners I've had have also
been good listeners and also just loving
okay why different quotations around
loving oh that's my own personal trauma
it's because you're ugly what happens
when you're an unattractive man to them
is that your love looks like clinginess
if you're a hot dude you're sweet you
can you're a character yeah if you're an
unattractive person well you're exactly
and you're creepy you're annoying you're
probably a stalker yeah because who
would love someone who looks like you
that's what they're saying okay that's
all it is rough but rough but yeah hello
tell me about yourself God a lot I like
to go to medium festivals well the crazy
one
um
some butter ice yes some butter eyes
gave me crazy Vibes roll that [ __ ] back
at what you said the crazy one look at
how how it looked yeah I confirmed that
[ __ ] like a donkey perm let's see you
got a lot you got a lot of red yeah
wild and crazy huh okay and what is your
relationship status right now I think
I think but still
are you dating other people as well or
just your ex I'm not really dating maybe
just like [ __ ] to cope wow powerful
she said [ __ ] to cope
that's a good lay
that's a good play that is head with no
self-respect shout outs to you
girlfriend keep doing your thing
I scared running down the face type of
tea I don't want to live this live
anymore so I just I don't care if I
don't breathe
I understand the black struggle on
camera
[Music]
you ever cheat no so how would you feel
if somebody did you know the fish sauce
probably poured in their car yeah you
the crazy one yo go ahead take that yes
Avery you're the crazy one congrats yeah
okay okay
is how fast she said that she had a plan
it like she did it before crazy congrats
okay okay all right
hello how long and like after you meet
someone would you want to have sex I'm
demisexual so like a gender neutral [ __ ]
boy that's him I still think he's the
habitual Girl star maybe I got three
right and if I'm being optimistic four
raise your hands off you got you right
oh what only got one right okay okay
yeah nice okay I'm happy about that one
go ahead and switch signs to the sign
that's yours yeah no I knew it and
habitual goes to what I tell you [ __ ]
habitual ghost sir mama's boy she's
clingy as [ __ ] okay clingy as [ __ ] is
the crazy one is the same [ __ ] could be
it's the same thing it could be
clinginess like itching clinginess
that's crazy what you mean it's what it
is
he's the one that's just like always
there like a bit needy always there it
always needs okay what is clingy as [ __ ]
an extreme of being always there yeah oh
I see what you're saying that's the [ __ ]
I was just listening to clingy yeah you
got the whole her cleanest [ __ ] is if
you cheat on me I'm grabbing fish sauce
on point [ __ ] you're crazy that's crazy
yeah yeah no that's great fair I was
just listening to cleaning we got [ __ ]
boy right
yeah [ __ ] boy right mama's boy correct
um I thought she was hopeless Romantics
I got that one wrong total package we
got right I got habitual ghoster right
and this one's crazy package no sorry
you're crazy girl is crazy you can see
it in the eyes and like you know I don't
know what it's about crazy people but
they always feel the need to dye their
hair and dress a little funky because
they're they can't hide they're crazy
you know what I'm saying but it's the
eyes you really find it in the eyes it's
not even sometimes like the eyes are big
it's just the way that they stare at you
sound or something the way that they
stare at you like they're looking
through you and seeing the person you're
gonna be for them like it's there's like
the crazy eye is just like astrology
it's not a science you just know I've
never missed crazy no I've Seen Crazy
coming sometimes I ran into crazy
because crazy was hot and I dealt with
the crazy consequences but I saw crazy
coming from crazy away yeah you get what
I'm saying yeah you never miss crazy if
your eyes are open yeah
just check the Instagram they can't hide
the crazy it's there it's there in the
details I wish I could like the devil I
wish I could teach someone the crazy
like this is crazy I just know it you
know yeah I didn't like put my hands on
it I'm like yo yeah that's you have to
it's like you have to work in customer
service or encounter enough crazy to be
like that's crazy if you encounter if
you live in L.A or you live in New York
or live in a place where it's like it's
very like a big city and you've
encountered enough crackheads you know
crazy clingy as [ __ ] damn I was close
though you're not crazy you're clingy
yeah that's that crazy that's what I
said I'll make sure you clean I get like
separation anxiety yeah you're like a
puppy yeah like a lost puppy but does
your ex-boyfriend know this is you like
yeah he he knows even though I had my
own car I would make him drive me to
work just to be in the car with me so to
be honest I just think she knows her
worth so good for you I think you should
keep making the men in your life they
work too get the [ __ ] out of here get
get the [ __ ] out of here what you
talking about her worth [ __ ] is crazy
don't enable this [ __ ] I made him drive
me to work because I didn't want to be
separated him for a second but I have my
own car that's crazy
it's
that's crazy
yo you [ __ ] are bugging you
know your own see that talking about
this yes Queen thing that's what it is
that's what it is if a dude was telling
this girl to do that yeah make her drive
me to work you [ __ ] bum you look
this is crazy and it's not even like
there's an issue with giving your girl
right to work but making somebody do
that because you don't want to be
separated from them that's creepy
is that not creepy
yeah I want to drop off my girl to work
every morning because I want to watch
her go into the job and come back out no
no I have my own car but I make her
drive me so that ain't gonna get
separated this is creepy it's worse the
crazy one yes and you really got me on
that all right what makes you crazy
um I'm just bipolar and I never take my
medication okay okay so I dealt with
this not long ago okay someone who was
I'm pretty sure
borderline undiagnosed like and I don't
see that lightly because I've never said
that about anyone I've ever dated but
the mood swings were in sync you know
what I'm saying like you're the best
person in the world crying hysterically
knife to the neck hope you die like
stuff like that like you're just like
what's happening right now this is
something I've had to learn firsthand if
you are in a relationship with somebody
who's going through that one you can't
do it if they're not medicating or
they're not treating and two you just
have to accept that you're gonna have to
do a whole lot more emotional labor than
they will
you will have to compromise way more
you're gonna have to do a lot more it's
kind of like being in a relationship
with somebody who has a disability like
a physical one but you're gonna have to
do a lot more physically in terms of
Labor to be able to compensate to make
anything work now some people are okay
with that there's nothing wrong with it
but just know that if you're going in if
one of you are thinking about doing it
but you're not willing to take on that
emotional like I gotta compromise way
more I gotta do this don't do it and I
understand there's a different reason
why someone in that position wouldn't
want to take it offensive medication I
hear you why is she not taking that
medication because the medication can
[ __ ] you up
the side effects are real but
you dealing with that person you can't
do nothing you can't help that you don't
you can't help that person if you try to
help that person you're gonna sacrifice
yourself doing so I was gonna ask I
think you were saving [ __ ] boy for me
though I was safe I was saving it but
like after talking to you honestly I got
I don't I don't I didn't get that but I
think you're a cool dude and I think
that you probably have a lot of positive
qualities I think that nobody is the
total package
I'm gonna say this right now he would
not have the same speech if it was a
black woman holding that [ __ ]
I would have loved to see this man
go out to any proud woman black white
age don't care black I'm the total
package there's no such thing as little
packages uh excuse me honey excuse me
honey yeah you're not saying that you're
not saying that [ __ ] excuse me honey get
the [ __ ] out of here the [ __ ] I am yeah
boy yeah yeah see what ladies are we're
super confident what we call that either
[ __ ] or yes Queen when dudes do it
what is it it's cool or it's super cocky
there again
but you're not gonna tell no [ __ ]
trans woman you're not gonna tell no
[ __ ] person in drag that they're not
the total package that's not gonna
happen you're not saying that tonight
yeah you'd be like you know what yes
[ __ ] that's what you be saying that's
Queen that's Queen let's keep it a set I
would agree kind of like a a synonym
would be like a good partner right and
that's what I kind of identify as just
this comes as a shock to me like now
that like I see you with that tag I kind
of I kind of see where it's like oh if
you're not an emotionally attached I'm
out exactly bro how did you guys not
know this guy was a habitual ghoster
[ __ ] came on this set looking
like Casper look at him look at him
like I feel like I used to act a lot
more like a fuckboy but the ghoster has
always been the thing that stayed
because I'd be like hey let's do things
and then the next day I'm like nevermind
I have kind of three strikes rules
someone hurts me two times three times
I'm like okay I never speak to you again
ah you ghosts but only as
a consequence of mistreatment
so you're good oh my God so it's like
self-defense mechanisms
I mean I I can understand it actually
yeah somebody to go there no no it's
because if somebody hurts you you don't
owe them a conversation yeah I
understand yeah you know I mean like if
somebody cheats on you multiple times
why would you need to feel the need to
relay conversation why do you have to go
through that process
so I'm not mad at him for that I'm
actually that makes a lot of sense
that's actually the circumstance where
it makes the most sense it's like if you
had an abusive relationship I wouldn't
be like oh yeah you open up
conversations no Deuces why did you go
me that's a different story
that's a different story I that's you I
did it for them you know what I'm saying
oh for their ego you know shut the [ __ ]
because they couldn't handle oh hell no
hell no we're not doing this we're not
doing this we're not we're not what
we're not doing this we're not doing
what what you asking me
for them you know it's it's a [ __ ]
you know you full of it down no I don't
I think a lot of people nowadays are
non-confrontational and they don't want
to hear it I ain't mad at you but
hey yo listen listen this is something
that's happened to me numerous times
where I'm like I don't want us to keep
seeing each other or even like after two
dates we need to sleep together don't
want if you've seen each other and women
will try to convince you to change your
mind like crazy
get I guess man yeah yeah yeah well
listen I date women's I'm just saying
that but they will try to change your
mind
and then you're like fine another you
know if you got to break up with them
again they're gonna try again I'm like
bro I can't be bothered like let me just
not respond that's happened to me for
sure
I would state in the relationship for an
extra year
because a girl asked me to
God damn but that's like
yeah you say God damn there's people who
stay married for that long for 10 years
sure there's people who stay in
relationships five six years of that you
know what I'm saying sure one year is
nothing sure yeah an extra year is
nothing you know like I already knew it
was over but this person you know what I
mean like obviously if you love the
person you don't want to see them hurt
and you try to tell them but they try to
change your mind you're like wow they
start crying you feel bad it's very easy
yeah to get LinkedIn like that yeah you
know so it's just like you try to have a
conversation some people don't want to
hear what you have to say at all like
I've had breakups okay well I had like
things that stopped and I thought it was
good I'm still getting emails two years
later and sometimes it's not even a
breakup sometimes it's just you're just
gonna explain something and it leads to
a breakup because you see that the
person doesn't want to even hear
anything
they don't want to hear nothing yeah I
can understand that anything you say but
yeah but this but this I'm not in it
anymore like this is not it's not
working for you we don't have the same
goals whatever it doesn't matter I'll
change I'll change everything you mean
you won't change you're gonna change
your core being like that's not real
so sometimes you just gotta walk away
maybe that's ghosting and there's been
other times where I'm just like but I
don't wanna and I just didn't that's the
piece of [ __ ] moment but there's the
other side where it's like that's not
ghosting
I was like I can't talk to you I
understand because you're not talking to
me you're just trying to go you know
there's some people that are going to
say that he ghosted me but it's like but
you're not listening it's like I gave
you many times told you like yo I don't
want this but you keep I didn't go shoot
you kept on replying when I said I don't
want this anymore and this is over yo
listen one time the girl said the most
foul thing to me that I ever heard in my
life so remember I told you about the
borderline person yeah this person told
me
to go off myself oh yeah
right like you're worthless you should
offer yourself mind you nothing terrible
happened nothing bad happened very minor
disagreement about something just
escalate but again with borderline it
doesn't have to make sense no okay
things can escalate from a minor
disagreement to something way bigger
okay and it doesn't make sense because
you're like Abba who does that what I'm
trying to explain to you is like it
doesn't have to make sense if you see
the [ __ ] message 30 but wait what
happened between two point eight point B
but I was also trying to rationalize
that in my head so when I'm seeing these
messages and I'm like I've never
received messages like that in my entire
life I'm not going to continue engaging
what would I look like I look like
stupid
trying to reply so you can send more
messages like that so me I'm just like
all right well this this is way too much
for I can't handle that so I just have
to walk away from that conversation but
um I don't consider stuff like that
ghosting I think it's just a bit of
self-preservation that you have to
engage in for your own mental well-being
but that's my opinion makes sense yeah
anyways
what'd you guys think about today's
episode did you guys like her insights
or not we want to hear from you
that's crazy